Bu nasıl diyeyim ben ismi Burcu Karakaş
mesleğe 12 sene önce başladım 12'den
önce başladım Milliyet gazetesine
başladım Benim bu şekilde sunum
olmayacak ama size Aslında işin yani
kahvecilik üzerinden merakla ilgili bir
şeyler anlatmak istiyorum Evet yani
Şahsen ben lisede okurken Koç mevzuyu
Tabi beni bir bende yani şanslı kesin
benim diyebilirim şu açıdan hani İşte
tabi çoğunlukla mesela İngilizce için
aslında özel okulda okumuş olmanın bir
avantajı olduğu düştüğümüz ama sadece bu
da değil yani ne yazık ki devlet
okullarında yada Türkiye'deki Çoğu
okulda eğitim sistemi ezber üzerine
olduğu için etkinlikler çok haklı oluyor
ve Hani bugünden geri dönüp baktığın
zaman lisede yapılan organizasyonlar
işte ne bileyim ed
o günleri olsun ya da çeşitli buna
benzer günlerin Aslında benim kişisel
gelişimi diyeyim ya orada çok seviyorum
ama yani bir genç zamanımı çok iyi
anlamda etkilediğini fark ediyorum yani
mesela çok basitinden şöyle bir söylüyor
şimdi ben çok edebiyata meraklıydı o
zaman da öyleydim Şimdi de öyle yap
zaten yıldızıyla böyle işgal etmenin bir
sonucu olarak da şu an Neşe gazeteci
olarak şu an karşınızda duruyorum
diyebilirim Ee edebiyat günleri
kapsamında o zaman edebiyat hocamız beni
değişik görevlendirmişti bir sene Hatta
ben galiba ilgilenmiştir bütün gideriz
konutlarla o zaman şu anda Türkiye'de
olmayan ve yani işte ne çıkacağını
zamanda ama edebiyat ve belgeselde haşır
neşir olan Can Dündar nesi okulda
gelmişti ben de o zaman çok kitabını
okumuştum yani okuyordum işte metal Can
o can Gündere Ben okulda karşıladım
kendisi ile ilgilen demişti Ondan sonra
bunu etkinlik boyunca vesaire tabi sonra
yıllar sonra meslektaş oldu ve aynı
gazetede bir arada olduk Evet böyle
söyleyince çok şey hani böyle iki
cümlede söylüyorsunuz ama arkada insan
için böyle çok nasıl diyeyim Duygusal
açıdan hoş yani duygular veren bir şey o
yüzden ne sizin de eminim öyle
zannediyorum herkesin gençliğinde böyle
idealize ettiği insanlar vardı yani
hangi alana ilgi duyuyorsanız o alan
Hani ben edebiyat ve işte kahvecilik
alanında olduğu için mesela o bir örnek
son O yüzden aslında en başta belki ev
Bu seçimin başta söylediğim Belki de ona
hiçbir şey imkansız değil bir kere
birincisi sonrasında ben nasıl
taksiciliğe Aslında adım attığımı şimdi
bir kere size Muhtemelen size de şunu
soruyorlardı Çünkü dünyanın her yerinden
özellikle Türkiye'de ne olmak istiyorsun
sorusunu çok sorarlar
E tabii ki insan ne olduğunu nereden
bilecek Çünkü ne olduğunu bilmeniz için
ne yapmak istemediğiniz Öncelikle
öğrenmeniz gerekir yani Öğrenmek değil
de bulmamız gerekirdi Daha doğrusu ben
şimdi senden sonra var mı
Üniversitesi'nde siyaset bilimi olsa
çıktı okudum çok daha severek okudum
ancak Bizim bölümden mezun olanlar
genelde ya işte bankalarda işe giderdi
Hani Özel sektörde ya da kamuda giderdi
ben ikisini de istemiyordum yani
istemediğin zaman zaman bir şekilde
amacı mezun olduktan sonra Tabi ki de
işten alanlar geleceksiniz Ne
yapacaksınız böyle yazıyorum çiziyorum
okuyorum ne yapabilirim yani gazetecilik
aklının bir köşesinde belki vardı ama
açıkçası yani maddi olarak kendini
döndüre bileceğin bir meslek olarak
görmedim için çok da üstüne düşmemiştir
ancak üniversiteyi bitirdikten sonra
çoğu gencin yaptığı gibi ben de yüksek
lisans için başvurdum yine bir şekilde
denk geldi ve işte Yani hem
O öyle işte ben de Tabii bu kadar da
temel bir öğrenci değildim yani
yurtdışına gittim Boston
Üniversitesi'nde usas işleme ustası
iletişim okudu üniversitede okurken
Milliyet Gazetesi'nde yani 2008'de gitti
lan 2013'te iki sene 2009 yılında
Milliyet gazetesinde bir taş imkanı
buldum ve genelde şöyle bir şey var yani
sorarlarsa İngilizce biliyor musun
biliyorum O zaman seni böyle otomatik
olarak dış haberler servisi ne ki
gönderirler beni de oraya gönderdi ama
dış haberler servisi çoğunu da çevir
üzerine olduğu için Aslında çok ilgimi
de bir noktadan sonra çekmedi Çünkü ben
daha sahada olmak haber yapmak
insanlarla konuşmak ne ya aslında merak
ettiğim şeyleri araştırmak istiyorum
hani gazetecilikte Aslında bu çok
elverişli bir alan Tabi ki yani
akademisyenlik mesela böyle ama bizim
alan hakikaten ve biraz aslında bir
günlük günlük Gündem içinde biraz bu
oluyorsunuz ben
O belli bir noktaya geldikten sonra
istediğiniz Araştırmayı da yapıp kamuya
bunu sana biliyorsunuz ben bunu çok
kıymetli bir şey olduğunu düşünüyorum
nihayetinde Birlik gazetesinin haberi
araştırma servisi istihbarat artı diye
bir bölümü var yani her etmedi
kuruluşunda olur Ben de kendi sistemi
oraya geç Hatta ben oraya geçtim zaman
biliyorum Böylece gazete içinde şehri
anlar olmuştu Çünkü biraz şeydir nasıl
diyeyim e gazetecinin Aslında temeli bu
ha birliktir ve muhabirlik çok kıymetli
bir şeydir yani Zaten Dünyanın her
yerinde böyle ama Türkiye'de böyle bir
köşe yazarlığı Müessesesi diye bir şey
var ben çok boş bir alan Yani boş bir iş
oldu düşüncem açıkçası Çünkü köşe
yazarlığı Yani bugün hava çok sıcak
Allah'ım işte ben de çok terledim falan
tarzı Yazdığınız yazının Yani çok da
Analitik ya da insana bir şey katılmış
olur düşünmüyorum Tabii eğlenceli
olabilir ama bu ha Birlik dediğiniz
sahaya inerek
bu anlara işte soru sorarak araştırarak
bir şekilde onu okuyucuya da izleyici
sunmaktır dış haberler servisinde
istihbarata geçtiğin zaman ben biliyorum
ki insanlar Biraz şey oldu gazetede bu
kızı niye oraya geçti acaba Hani yani
dış haberler servisi böyle daha havalı
bir şey falan gibi duruyor ama
istihbarat servisine böyle adliyeye
gidersin Ne bileyim bir yerde bir olay
olur oraya takip ederse Abi ben şöyle
düşünmeli ve oraya geçti mi bir dakika
bile pişman olmadım zaten olmam gereken
yer burasıydı ev minik gazetesi ispat
sarısı geçtikten sonra ara Türkiye'nin
çoğu yerine gazeteci olarak gezme imkanı
da eriştim bunaldığında çok mutluyum
yani hakikaten Hani birçok şehri işte ne
bileyim mesela Van'da 2011 yılında
hatırlarsınız belki deprem olduğu zaman
mesela Hani oraya gidiyorsun onun
haricinde Ben daha çok çocuk ve kadın
hakları alanında da haberler yapıyorum
Enes ülkemiz bu alanda
bu haberi bol bir yer olduğu için örnek
veriyorum bir şehirde diyelim ki çocuk
istismarı ile ilgili bir dosyada bir
haber oluyor Hadi atmıyorum oraya
gidiyorum işte onu artık oldu kadar
konuyu araştırıyorsun ediyorsun vesaire
ve hani böyle olayları olduğu yerde ne
takip etmeye başladım ve bu bana
hakikaten çok iyi geldi yani ama mesaj
Şunu fark ettim hakikaten Sen 34
yaşındayım Hani Hayatımda en çok
sevdiğim şey mesleğim Bazen bu çok iyi
bir şey olmayabilirsin düşünüyorum Ama
eğer gerçekten gazeteciliği her şeyden
çok seviyorum bu kadar zorluğa rağmen ne
zaman zaman kendime diyorum ki yani Hani
nasıl bu duyguya erişti ya da hala bu
duyguyu nasıl içinde barındırabilir
yorum Çünkü bu kadar yani zor koşullarda
erken işte hani ülkenin politik
atmosferdir vesaire birçok şarkısından
zor tabii ki manevi açıdan zor olduğu
kadar maddi açıdan lazım
O eve o şu aslında bana gazetecilik her
gün yeni bir şey öğrenme fırsatı sunuyor
bu her meslekte böyle olmayabilir asla
Yani çoğu meslekti Elbette ki bir şeyler
hani ya kendinizi tamamen kapatıyorsunuz
anlamında değil Ama birincisi yeni
insanlarla tanışma fırsatı bunu çok
kuvvetli olduğunu düşünüyorum Yeni
konular üzerine bilgi edinme araştırma
fırsatı ve ama en önemlisi merak
duygumuzu giderme fırsatı Evet ya bazen
Yani artık bence sayıları çok az ama
hala şey gazeteci olan gençler olmak
isteyen gençler var ya da onlarla bir
araya geldiğim zaman hani sorarlar hep
ne önerirsiniz ne yapabiliriz ne
yapmalıyız bu bu meslek için ben de her
zaman için şunu söylüyorum yani
Özellikle mu haber olmayı düşünüyorsanız
en haber yapma
Evet Ee merak etmiyorsanız merakınız
yoksa ben de zaten hiç yani başlamadan
bitirebilirsiniz o yolculuğu gibi
geliyor bana Neden Çünkü Mesela ben
gazeteye girdikten sonra hali kalemi
miydi Tamam ama haber yapma ayrı bir
şeyler haber formatı yani böyle Dört
başı mamur bir haber yazma başka bir şey
edebi tür ayrı bir şey oyası farklı ve
asla bakın zaman ben haber yazmayım
haykin yüksek lisansını işte şeker sesi
üzerine yapmıştım Tabi ki de teori
öğrendiğinizde bu bütün meslekler için
geçerli diye düşünüyorum Bu arada teori
ve pratik her zaman aynı olmuyor
birbirinden farklı oluyor Yüksek
Samsun'da alanda yapmış olmama rağmen
Milli Gazete geldiği zaman haber
yazmakta bir süre zor aldığımı
hatırlıyorum yani istediğim gibi ol
olması gerektiği gibi hakikaten böyle
bir seneden fazla bir zamanımı aldı ama
sonrasında oldu bir öğrenci bir
tutturunca gidiyor buluşuyor
bu pratik yaparak bazı şeyler
açılabiliyor Bu da gene Bence Aslında
çoğu meslek için geçerli Ama benim
mesleğim içinde özellikle geçerli onu
bir şekilde halledersin Yani bir konuyu
bilmiyorsunuz dur okursunuz öğrenirsiniz
haber formatında alışkın değilsiniz dir
haber iyi haber yazmak için değil okumak
gerekiyor arıza tabi yazmakla gerekiyor
her onda bir şekilde öğrenirsiniz ama en
merak duygusu yoksa o bence Sonradan
edinilen bir şey değil o biraz insana
içselleştirme iyi bir şey ve içinde olan
bir şey diye düşünüyorum hani sadece
kendim için de değil açıkçası kendi yani
çevremde gördüğüm meslektaşlarım da hani
1010 seneyi de verebilmiş değilim çünkü
bu ülkede gazeteci kalmak sadece sizin
ne kadar İyi olduğunuza da bununla bağlı
değil tabii ki dış faktörler de vardır
Bunlar da önemli baktığınız zaman hani
Uzun sürede hakikaten hala bu beste
sözleri
Bye bye bye e o merak duygusunu tatmin
etme güdüsünü ben görüyorum ev Bu da
mesela nasıl mutlu tabi zaman bunları
söyleme ama bu ne anlama geliyor Mesaj
şöyle bir örnekleri en son yaptığım
haberden örnek vereyim şimdi
biliyorsunuz İstanbul sözleşmesi adlı
bir sözleşme var Türkiye bulunan
çekiciye yönünde bir çıkar alındı Ve
sonra çeşitli iddialar Çıktı işte
çevrilerek kanuna göre yani sözleşme
olsun olmasın kanuna göre e kadınlar bir
şekilde şiddet görüyorlarsa da böyle bir
tevhidi için delerse karakollara
savcılıklara gidip uzaklaştırma kararı
aldırabiliyor lar Bu zaten var Bu Şu
anda da var yani o sözleşme zaten
söylesene hala var ama hani soruları
girmeyeceğim şimdi bu tarz iddialar
şöyle dendi karakola giden kadınlar
kapıda dönüyor Hadi o başvuruları
alamıyor gibi bir şey söyledim şimdi bu
hiç haberler çıktığı
Ben de elimdeki günden malum birçok
Şeyle ilgileniyorum Hani yazık ki aynı
zamanda ama hani haberler çıktı bu
iddaalar çıktı şimdi işte Birileri bir
şey daha ediyor işte yetkililer diyor
Bütün ki öyle bir durum yok Birileri bir
şey söylüyorum bir şey yok şimdi bunu en
Yani en açık bir şekilde nasıl
anlayabilirim diye düşündüm karakola
giderek gerçekten şunu merak ettim
hakikaten karakol kapısına giden bir
kadın acaba orada başvurusu alıyorlar
yoksa almıyorlardı çok basit bir şey
aslında ne yaptım diyeceksiniz Peki ben
İstanbul'da üç tane şaka kola diktim
kapısına işte Selamünaleyküm
Aleykümselam Merhabalar Merhabalar işte
ben tabii ki cezası ciddiye gitmiyorum
Bu arada yarın Köye gitmiyorum Yani ben
uzaklaştırma kararı aldırmak istiyorum
diye gidiyorum kapıya uzaklaştırma
kararı aldırmak için burada bu
Ne yapayım canım olur mu diye gittim İki
tanesi Kadıköy'deki iskeledeki Polis
Amirliği yüzüme bakmadı savcılığa
gideceksiniz dedi Beyazıt'taki polis
karakolu şey o da dedi ki biz buradan
almıyoruz başka bir İlçe Emniyet
Müdürüne gideceksiniz dedi Karaköy'e
gittiğimde oradakiler birazcık daha
ilgilendi işini ben ne yaptım çünkü ben
birincisi asla bundan sonra haberini
hazırladı zaten o yüzden gitmiştim yani
gazeteci kılığında gitmedim belki Hani
mağdur kalın da gitti ama bunu niye
yaptın tabii ki haber yapmak için yaptım
ama Hepsinden önce merak ettiğim için
yaptım yani çünkü bana hiç kimse
Burcu'ya gitti şuna bir araştır demedi
onu da diyorlar Tabii ki de çünkü hani
ben tek başıma değilim benimle benim
hani üstünde çalışan editörler var de
sayede başka insanlarla birlikte
çalışıyor Onlar da bana haber ver
önerilerde bulunuyorlar e ancak
birilerinin önerdiği
ve yapmak yani Talip öyle bir durumunuz
varsa bir yaparsınız Ama insan Gerçekten
merak ettiği bir şey yapınca Bence
yaptığı işte iyi oluyor ya da benzer bir
şekilde ilgi duyduğu bir alan alanda bir
meslek sahibi olduğu zaman hayattan zevk
alıyor Çünkü hani benim işim geldi
gazetecilik As a bir iş değil böyle bir
hayat tarzı gibi biraz nasıl diyeyim
mesela şöyle düşünebiliriz bir Cerrah
gibi düşünün Tabi ki de kendimi bir
biçimde bir tutuyormuş alakası yok ya
benim yaptığım işte bir Hekim yaptı işte
aynı Tabii ki de değil ama hani nasıl
gibi ameliyat yani biri aradığı zaman
ameliyata girecek ya ben bugün ameliyat
yapmayacağım gibi bir durumla Hani acil
bir şey söyle bir şey söyleyemem
biliyorsanız ya da benim de şöyle bir
lüksüm yok Hani özellikle son dönemde
İşte insanların Gündem sebebiyle
özellikle yapacak Efendim zaman
zamanında bir haber okuma alışkanlıkları
değişti Artık biraz daha Yani daha az
bu Adana Haber tüketiyor haber okuyor
hani ben şey diyemiyorum ama bugün de
Bakmayacağım haberleri Vallahi çok
sıkıldım gidip bir şey deme lüksüm yok
bunu Bazen söyleyeyim mi Ben de
istiyorum Bu arada yani hakikaten
psikolojik olarak insanı çok yıpratan
bir şey bir anda ama diğer yandan da
zaten kendimi Aslında alamıyorum Ondan
yani bu dakikada insanı Bence dengede
tutması gerek bir şey yani bundan
övünerek de bahsediyormuş gibi gözükmek
istemem ki Her şeyin bir ayar olması
lazım ama şunu demek istiyorum Diğer den
sonra gazetecilik hayat hayat tarzınız
haline geliyor ederim ki bu çok sağlık
bir şey olmayabilir ama kendinden böyle
oluyor ve Zaten siz o akış içinde
aslında bir şeyler yapıyorsunuz Ama şey
şu var yani yorulması çok kolay bir
meslek Çünkü şöyle yani fiziksel olarak
yıpranmak eve Ama daha çok zihinsel ve
psikolojik açıdan yıpranmasına yazık Çok
en yüksek ki ben de asla son zamanlarda
zaten yıprandım hissediyorum açıkçası
yani Çok da bir yaşam belki yok ama ha
Nereden baksanız 11 yıldır devamlı
Gündem takip ederek Gündem hakkında
haber yapmaya çalışıyorum Bu Tabii ki
yorucu bir şey ama hep o noktada hep hep
şunu soruyorum yani Hala ben nasıl bu
işi bırakmıyorum Nasıl oldu da
bırakmadım işte Oo hep bu soruyu kendime
sorup kendine baktığın zaman hep Aslında
gördüm yani duyguları Hissettiğim şey
Orada aslında ki kat en bütün bu yaptım
konuşmalı ana Gündem maddesini
oluşturuyor deyip de merak duygusu Çünkü
merak edip bir şey araştırdığım zaman
hayat enerjisiyle dolduğunu hissediyorum
ya da araştırdığım bir konuyu kamuoyuna
sunduğum zaman sadece kendi meraklı
gidermiş olmuyorum aynı zamanda topluma
da bir şekilde hiz
bu ettiğim için Çünkü kansizlik Tabii ki
de böyle bir iş zaten kamuya hizmet
ediyorsunuz e o meraktan çıkan ürünü
haberi izleyici ile okuyucuya
paylaştığım zaman aldığım geri
bildirimde olumlu yönde olduğu için asla
mesleği sürdürme ve sağlayan bu olduğunu
görüyorum o yüzden sözlerimi toparlar
Ken Çünkü zannediyorum ki bana ayrılan
surenin Sonuna Geldik Keşke daha uzun
zaman uzun uzun konuşacağız Belki başka
zaman için o yüzden ben şunu söylemek
isterim galiba Hani liseden mezun
olduktan sonra artık ya da üniversiteden
Herneyse büyüdükten tırnak içinde ya
Neyse artık o Büyümek Hani erişkin
hayatını adım attıktan sonra o
merakınızı Neyse hangi alanda hangi
alana hissediyorsanız kaybetmemizi
diliyorum Çünkü onu kaybetmediğini zaman
hakikaten hepinizi çok iyi işler ortaya
koyacağını düşünüyorum çok teşekkür
ediyorum